a bit of housekeeping pre-signed books
will be available in the lobby from
garcia street books also for those of
you in the Eldorado hotel which I
understand now is standing room only
please come to the lens ik after the
event to get books well good evening
Santa Fe when a stylist a todos ustedes
bienvenidos I'm David bar Samuel and
welcome to one of the most anticipated
events of this or any other year noam
chomsky
and in fact stage I was joking with no
my held up this flyer it said sold out
which will be I think ammunition for his
enemies but rest assured Noam Chomsky
has never sold out
thanks to the Lenin foundations in
pursuit of cultural freedom series which
organized this event thanks also to
Lannon for an abling alternative radio
to digitize our noam chomsky audio
archive which now numbers close to 250
recordings you can go to alternative
radio org thanks Lana I started
alternative radio because of Noam
Chomsky I wrote him a letter you wrote
back
we started corresponding and after a
while I suggested we do an interview he
said yes of course that was 31 years ago
it's an honor for me to introduce Noam
Chomsky but how to introduce someone who
as they ritually say needs no
introduction well do something different
I thought like tell a story there's a
parable from the Sufi tradition called
the elephant in the dark
Sufism for those of you not familiar
with it is the esoteric inner dimension
of Islam Rumi and others have told this
story and I've added a bit to it it's
called the elephant in the dark some men
when women perhaps who've never seen an
elephant are blindfolded and are asked
to touch different parts of the elephant
and identify what they are touching so
one touches an ear and says it's a fan
another touches the tail and says
confidently it's got to be a rope
another touches the Tusk and says well
for sure it's a spear another a leg says
with great confidence oh it's a pillar
and on and on and on and they start
bickering among themselves each
adamantly insisting that he was right
their voices were getting louder and
louder and then along comes a sage who
tells them guys chill out
this is not in contempt I can hardly
imagine in the 13th century the sage
would say God is chill out but kind of
modernized a little bit let me remove
your blindfolds
see it's an elephant and they were all
flabbergasted for many of us all over
the world Noam Chomsky is that sage the
Sufi guide Murshid never showboating or
grand standing but simply laying out
what he sees backed up with a torrent of
facts and documentation he doesn't tell
you what to do but like the Sufis he
teaches by example the next step is up
to you you have to figure out your path
of societal involvement and action for
decades he's been illuminating the dark
crevices of a rapacious economic system
and an imperialist foreign policy and
always in a calm soft voice and listen
for the irony by any measure he's led a
most extraordinary life he's a pioneer
in the field of linguistics to call his
efforts tireless and his writings
prolific are huge understatements if
records are kept for such categories as
giving lectures and interviews writing
books and articles Chomsky would be
world champion at 86 he's still a rebel
without a pause and as they say in
Yiddish a mensch and yes here comes that
four-letter word children cover your
ears
love he is deeply loved by many I've
seen it on the faces of people from
Porto Alegre to Denver and it's no
wonder because he's been there for so
many from East Timor to Nicaragua from
Palestine to Colombia and this evening
he's here for us brothers and sisters
please welcome Noam Chomsky
[Applause]
it's now 70 years since the end of the
most horrific war in history it ended
with the use of an ultimate weapon which
can bring human history to an end a day
which I happen to remember very well
we've been living under that shadow ever
since 20 years later two of leading
figures of 20th century intellectual
life
Bertrand Russell Albert Einstein issued
an appeal to the people of the world
calling on them to face a choice that is
stark and dreadful and inescapable shall
we put an end to the human race
or shall mankind renounce war they
recognized of course that work and very
quickly turned into terminal nuclear war
in 1947 The Bulletin of Atomic
Scientists established its famous
Doomsday Clock setting at 7 minutes to
midnight midnight is the end last
January it was advanced to three minutes
before midnight that's a threat level
that had not been reached for 30 years
at a grim moment to which I'll return
the accompanying explanation invoked the
two major threats to human survival
nuclear war nuclear weapons and
unchecked climate change the Cole
condemned world leaders who are
endangering every person on earth by
failing to perform their most important
duty ensuring and preserving the health
and vitality of human civilization the
Russell Einstein appeal differs from the
current declaration in two crucial
respects one is that it did not include
the threat of environmental catastrophe
we
50 years ago was not sufficiently
understood and secondly it directly
addresses the people of the world not
the political leadership that this
difference is of some significance
there's substantial evidence that on
climate change nuclear weapons planning
international policies generally the
population seems much more concerned
than the political leadership who do not
regard their most important duty to be
insuring and preserving the health and
vitality of human civilization as ample
evidence reveals it's hardly a secret
that even in the most free and
democratic societies the governments
respond only in limited ways to popular
will for the United States it's
well-established in academic scholarship
that a considerable majority of the
population at the lower end of the
income wealth scale are effectively
disenfranchised their views are simply
ignored by policymakers influence
increases slowly as one moves up the
scale and at the very top which means a
fraction of 1% the policy is pretty much
determined that being the case the
attitudes at the top of the ladder are
of very great significance
these are revealed dramatically in a
poll of CEOs that was released last
January at the Davos conference in
Switzerland the conference of Masters of
the Universe as the business press
describes them by rather ominous
coincidence this was just at the moment
when the Doomsday Clock was advanced to
three minutes to midnight
the poll revealed that climate change
did not mirror inclusion among the top
19 risks that concern CEOs worse still
at the top of their ranking of perceived
risks was regulation that that is the
prime method for addressing
environmental catastrophe their
overriding concern was with growth
prospects for their companies that's not
surprising whatever their individual
beliefs in their institutional role the
CEOs are constrained to adopt policies
that are designed to pose extraordinary
and undeniable threats to the continued
existence of humanity in the words of
the Doomsday Clock declaration and given
their enormous role in determining state
policy it's less surprising that policy
lags behind public opinion on the
concerns that move the clock so close to
midnight the effects are before our eyes
every day so take last Sunday's Wall
Street Journal typical example there's a
weakened review section it's it features
an article entitled fossil fuels will
save the world really the lead story in
the news section is headlined US
producers ready new oil wave the article
glories and the thought of what they
call an ocean of oil from US shale as
American energy companies are poised to
unleash a further flood while they lead
us exuberantly to the precipice
scientists are well aware that most of
the oil must be left in the ground if
there's to be some hope for a decent
life for our grandchildren but who cares
as long as there are spectacular profits
for tomorrow
on international affairs as well a
popular opinion diverges significantly
from that of the decision-making classes
among many other examples a considerable
majority in the United States have held
that the United Nations not the US
should take the lead in international
crises such views are so remote from a
leat opinion that they're barely even
articulated publicly a good part of the
reason is the nature of a lead opinion
and as often is the case it's the
critical end of the spectrum that's the
most informative so here's an example
from a featured article by the former
director of the Carnegie Endowment for
international peace in the current issue
of the New York Review of Books leading
u.s. intellectual journal rather
left-liberal and orientation here's what
and she writes American contributions to
international security global economic
growth freedom and human wellbeing have
been so self-evidently unique and have
been so clearly directed to others
benefit that Americans have long
believed that the US amounts to a
different kind of country where others
push their national interests the US
tries to advance universal principles
well comment should be superfluous but
in what's important is that this is what
many in so-called enlightened circles
actually believe it's quite an
astonishing fact in a free society where
information is readily available and the
impact on policy is not obscured nuclear
weapons policy reveals very dramatically
how government and also the concentrated
domestic concentrations of power that
largely dominate governments
how both regard the principle that
ensuring and preserving the health and
vitality of human civilization is their
most important duty when we inquire we
discover that regrettably governments
have consistently not even considered
security of their own populations as a
particularly high priority it's rather
enlightening to review the record all
begin with some high points or maybe low
points so let's begin with the early
days of the ultimate weapon a time when
the United States had overwhelming
wealth and power a remarkable security
there was however a potential threat
International ICBMs with nuclear
warheads there's a standard scholarly
review of nuclear policies spy McGeorge
Bundy he was the national security
adviser for presidents Kennedy and
Johnson he had access to the highest
level documents he'd quote him now he
says the timely development of ballistic
missiles during the Eisenhower
administration is one of the best
achievements of those eight years yet
yet it is well to begin with a
recognition that both the United States
and the Soviet Union might be in much
less nuclear danger today if these
missiles had never been developed and he
then adds a remarkable comment he says
I'm aware of no serious contemporary
proposal in or out of either government
that ballistic missiles should somehow
be banned by agreement in short there
was apparently no thought of trying to
prevent the sole serious threat to the
United States the threat of utter
destruction rather the institutional
imperatives of state power prevailed
much as in the case of the
CEOs for whom the fate of the species is
of such little concern that it does not
even enter into the ranking of risks
furthermore these shocking facts seem to
arouse little interest or comment in
fact I've never seen a reference to them
it could the development of these
missiles have been prevented there might
have been opportunities one suggestive
indication is a proposal by Stalin in
1952 offering to allow Germany to be
unified with free elections on condition
that had not join a hostile military
alliance which was hardly an extreme
condition in the light of the history of
the preceding half-century Stalin's
proposal was taken seriously by the
respected political commentator James
Warburg but apart from him it was
ignored or ridiculed actually recent
scholarship has just begun to take a
different view the bitterly
anti-communist Soviet scholar autumn
olam Harvard takes the status of
Stalin's proposal to be an unresolved
mystery Washington he said wasted little
effort in flatly rejecting Moscow's
initiative on grounds that were
embarrassingly unconvincing leaving open
the basic question was Stalin genuinely
ready to sacrifice the newly created
German Democratic Republic
East Germany on the altar of real
democracy with consequences for world
peace and her American security that
could have been enormous
Melvin Lafleur was one of the most
respected cold war scholars that
recently published a review of research
in released Soviet archives he observes
that many scholars were surprised to
discover quoting him now that
Lavrentiy Beria
the sinister brutal head of the secret
police proposed that the Kremlin offer
the West to deal on the unification and
neutralization of Germany agreeing to
sacrifice the East German communist
regime to reduce east-west tensions and
improve internal political and economic
conditions in Russia opportunities that
were squandered in favor of securing
German participation in NATO it's
actually a shocking decision that is
being relived right now under the
circumstances of the early 50s it's not
impossible that agreements might have
been reached that would have protected
the security of the US population from
the gravest threat on the horizon but
the option apparently was not even
considered and possible opportunities
were dismissed with ridicule another
indication of how slight a role
authentic security plays in state policy
and to heighten the extraordinary
significance of this failure it was just
at that time that the Doomsday Clock was
moved to two minutes to midnight the
closest it has ever been these events
from the early days of the Cold War have
considerable resonance right now right
at the borders of Russia in Ukraine for
serious crisis that traces right back to
the end of the Cold War a crucial issue
at that time around 1990 had to do with
the fate of NATO
now that the alleged threat of Russian
invasion had disappeared one might have
believed that NATO would have dissolved
quite the contrary
expanded radically mikhail gorbachev
agreed to allow a unified germany to
join nato rather significant concession
but there was a quid pro quo
namely that nato would not expand one
inch to the east
that was the phrase that was used in
high-level internal discussions
referring to East Germany NATO at once
expanded the East Germany Gorbachev
naturally objected but he was informed
by Washington that these were only
verbal commitments nothing in writing
the kind of unspoken implication is that
if you're naive enough to accept the
verbal gentleman's agreement with the
United States it's your problem
Clinton came along and expanded NATO to
the borders of Russia and as another
leading international relations scholar
John Mearsheimer recently pointed out in
the major establishment Journal foreign
affairs he pointed out that the
indications that Ukraine might be
assimilated into the Western system
possibly even into NATO could not fail
to be threatening to any Russian leader
we need only imagine how the United
States would have reacted at the height
of Soviet power
if the Warsaw Pact had taken over most
of this hemisphere and now Mexico were
preparing to join the Russian run
military alliance last December the
western-backed Ukrainian Parliament
voted 303 to 8 to rescind the policy of
non-alignment that had been adapted
adopted by the ousted president and they
committed Ukraine in their words to
deepen cooperation with NATO in order to
achieve the criteria required for
membership in this organization the
growing crisis concerning Ukraine is no
slight threat and it is an avoidable one
by diplomatic steps to guarantee
Ukrainian neutrality steps which
regrettably are not being taken well
returning to the 1950s
other developments reveal the low
priority assigned to authentic security
when Nikita Khrushchev took over after
Stalin's death he recognized that Russia
could not compete militarily with the
United States and that if Russia hoped
to escape its economic backwardness and
the devastating effect of the war the
arms race would have to be reversed
accordingly he proposed sharp mutual
reductions in offensive weapons the
incoming Kennedy administration
considered his offer and rejected it
instead turning to rapid military
expansion the policies are summarized by
distinguished international relations
scholarly Kenneth walls pointed out that
the Kennedy administration undertook the
largest strategic and conventional
peacetime military buildup the world has
yet seen even as first Jeff was trying
at once to carry through a major
reduction in conventional forces and to
follow a strategy of
minimum deterrence and we did so even
though the balance of strategic weapons
greatly favored the United States well
once again the decision u.s. decision
severely harmed national security while
enhancing state power how severely it
harmed national security was revealed in
1962 when Khrushchev sent missiles to
Cuba partially that was a foolhardy
attempt to write the balance partially
it was because of the very clear threat
of US invasion in the course of a major
terrorist campaign that Kennedy was
waging against Cuba kind of erased from
our history but very much alive in real
history
Khrushchev's effort to set off what
arthur schlesinger called the most
dangerous moment in history what happens
happened then
America's clear careful consideration no
time to go through the details but it's
worth remembering that at the peak
moment of the crisis October 26th and
27th of 1962 Kennedy received a letter
from Khrushchev offering to end the
crisis peacefully by simultaneous public
withdrawal of Cuban of Russian missiles
from Cuba and US missiles from Turkey
these were Jupiter missiles liquid
propelled meaning slow to set in motion
which means that they were for strike
weapons not intended for a deterrent
they were also obsolete weapons the US
had already issued an offer and had a
Tory issued in order to withdraw them
because they were being replaced by even
more lethal weapons invulnerable Polaris
submarines
so that was Kennedy's choice shall we
publicly withdraw obsolete missiles from
first strike missiles from Turkey on the
border of Russia which are being
replaced by even more lethal mass
missiles or to refuse he refused his own
estimates objective estimate of nuclear
war at the time was between 1/3 and 1/2
that's in my view one of the most
appalling decisions in history and even
more appalling is that Kennedy is
praised for his cool courage in handling
the crisis well 10 years later Henry
Kissinger called a nuclear alert this
was in the last days of the 1973 Israel
Arab war the purpose of the alert was to
warn the Russians not to interfere with
his delicate dip
maduk manoeuvres these were designed to
ensure an Israeli victory but a limited
victory so that the US would still be in
control of the region unilaterally and
the maneuvers were delicate we've
learned a lot about them from recent
Declassified sources the United States
out the United States and Russia had
jointly imposed a ceasefire but
Kissinger secretly informed Israel that
they could ignore hence the need for a
nuclear alert to frighten the Russians
away unfortunately they were frightened
away security of the population was a
matter of little concern as usual ten
years after that the Reagan
administration launched operations to
probe Russian defenses that meant
simulating air and naval attacks against
Russia that these actions were
undertaken at a very tense moment right
at that time pursing two missiles were
being installed in Western Europe these
at a five to ten minute flight time to
Moscow very destructive missiles also
Reagan had announced his so-called Star
Wars program which is presented here as
if it were defensive but every strategic
analyst on all sides understands that
missile defense is a first-strike weapon
if missile defense ever worked which it
might not it could not stop a first
strike but it conceivably might stop a
retaliatory strike which means it's a
first strike weapon and that was being
installed at the time all of this very
seriously caused great alarm in Russia
especially with the simulated attacks
that led to a major war scare in 1983
that was the last time that the Doomsday
Clock reached three minutes three
minutes before midnight
in 84 newly-released
Russian archives revealed that the
danger was even more severe than
historians had previously assumed
there's a recent comprehensive US
intelligence study which runs through
the evidence now available and concludes
in its words the war scare was for real
and they conclude he concludes that US
intelligence underestimated Russian
concerns and underestimated the threat
of a Russian preventive nuclear strike
which would have been the end recently
we've learned that it was even more
dangerous than that in the midst of
these world threatening developments
Russia's early warning systems detected
an incoming missile strike from the
United States sending the highest level
alert the officer on duty the Russian
officer on duty stanislav petrov decided
that it was a false alarm and he did not
transmit the warnings violating protocol
that was the difference between survival
and extermination Russian air defense
systems are much less sophisticated than
those of the United States they pretty
much rely on radar which means
line-of-sight recta detection of
incoming missiles u.s. systems rely on
satellites we can detect them at the
point of launch so the Russian systems
are on much more tense alert of great
danger to us of course well twenty years
before that back in the Cuban Missile
Crisis a Russian submarine commander
named Vasili arkhipov blocked the
launching of nuclear tipped torpedoes
which could have set off a terminal
nuclear war - there were three
submarines Russian submarines the two
other commanders had authorized the
launch when the three submarines were
under attack by US destroyers
during the Missile Crisis according to
the protocol the agreement of all three
was required arkhipov refused to agree
yet another sign of how thin is the
thread that we grasped for survival
there are chilling estimates about
failures of us systems which as I
mentioned are surely far more reliable
than the Russian ones there's a recent
review in The Bulletin of the Atomic
Scientists of several years of data on
us accidental reports of Soviet military
launches by the automated systems
aborted by human intervention hundreds
of these these were right in those years
of the greatest dangers 1979 to 1983 the
author of the review Seth Baum concludes
that nuclear war is the Black Swan we
can never see except in that brief
moment when it's killing us we delay
eliminating the risk at our own peril
now is the time to address the threat
because now we are still alive the
former commander of Stratcom general lee
butler recently reviewed his long career
as a strategic weapons planner and he
wrote that he had been among the most
avid of these keepers of the faith in
nuclear weapons but now it is his burden
to declare with all of the conviction I
can muster that in my judgment they
served us extremely ill and he outlines
the reasons like the ones I've mentioned
and he then raises a haunting question
by what authority through succeeding
generations of leaders
in the nuclear weapon states usurped the
power to dictate the odds of continued
life on our planet most urgently why
does such breathtaking audacity persist
at a moment when we should stand
trembling in the face of our folly and
united in our commitment to abolish its
most deadly manifestations the general
Butler went on to conclude that we have
so far survived the nuclear age by some
combination of skill let Luck and divine
intervention and I suspect the latter in
greatest proportion looking over the
record one can understand his judgment
plainly these are not risks that would
be accepted by any sane decision-maker
they are being accepted by decision
makers who are perfectly sane just as
the devastating risks of environmental
catastrophe are being faced with eyes
open and ignored by the Masters of the
Universe
all of them are trapped by an
institutional logic that is deeply
pathological and that must be cured and
quickly if we are not to put an end to
the human race in Russell and Einstein's
words thanks
[Applause]
hello again these lights are super
bright well what's it like being a Sufi
sage or what's it like like being a Sufi
sage and Sufi shave just assuming I
promised that I would do something
different in introducing him but you
ended that very cheerful talk did I miss
something
all are trapped by an institutional
logic that is deeply pathological and
that must be cured and quickly if we are
not to put an end to the human race how
do we go about doing that it's easy it's
all in our hands in the case of nuclear
weapons actually the answer is known
there are ways to end the threat of
nuclear weapons
furthermore as many of you know it's a
an obligation of the nuclear weapon
states to carry out good faith measure
efforts to eliminate nuclear weapons
totally that's article 6 of the
non-proliferation treaty of 1970
that's furthermore a legal obligation as
the International Court of Justice ruled
some years later in 1996 and those
efforts could be carried out in
unfortunately we're going in the
opposite direction so President Obama
has recently announced a trillion dollar
program to modernize and upgrade our
nuclear weapons capacity or attack
capacity other other powers are acting
more or less similarly there are
policies being conducted right now I
mentioned Ukraine but it's not the only
one that are bringing the global
situation to the point where it might
lead to a perhaps accidental crack
perhaps intended nuclear strike
incidentally it's been known for many
years decades that if a power launches a
nuclear strike first strike it will be
destroyed by the effects of the nuclear
explosions so there's no escape its any
nuclear war between any powers with any
capacity will lead to virtual
extermination we know how to end it but
the steps that are being conducted are
in the opposite direction and there have
been some potential
unfortunately aborted efforts to
implement steps that would reduce the
danger so one major threat right now has
to do with Iran in the United States
it's commonly claimed by high officials
commentators and others that Iran is the
greatest threat to world peace it's kind
of interesting to compare this with
global opinion there are polls of global
opinion taken by US polling agencies
Shalit whole major one the most recent
about a year ago did ask people around
the world which country is the greatest
threat to world peace the United States
won by a huge margin and nobody else was
even close
the second was Pakistan which was
probably inflated by the Indian vote but
that's but
unfortunately Americans are spared
knowledge of these facts the press
refuse to report them but they're facts
nevertheless anyway here it's Iran it's
the greatest threat to world peace
interesting questions the one can ask
about just what the threat is but let's
say there's a threat whatever it may be
is there a way to end it yeah there are
ways to end it I don't if you want me to
go into it but we're kind of stick to
the 5 min 5 minute lecture what I wanted
yell to them tell them what that later
overhears as I shouldn't but but there
have been potential steps which have
been blocked by the United States
that's unfortunate anyway in the case of
nuclear weapons we know how to end the
problem it's feasible it's a matter of
implementing policies that are
understood and they could be carried out
if there were sufficient popular
pressure to compel them to be carried
out the populations of the world care
about survival their leaders typically
don't they care about power and we can
influence those decisions particularly
in countries like this more free and
open societies with regard to
environmental catastrophe it's not so
obvious as a solution there are measures
that can be undertaken to mitigate the
threats and maybe to overcome them
that's an open question but again policy
is going in the opposite direction what
I quoted from The Wall Street Journal is
unfortunately pretty typical you read it
in the business presses of the business
pages of the press across the spectrum
York Times Financial Times others plenty
of euphoria about how the United States
can become the Saudi Arabia of the 21st
century it can achieve energy
independence we can flood the world with
oil all great and one
the price of oil is going down which is
great means good for American consumers
who can drive more and all of these
marvelous things are simply very
straightforwardly driving us towards a
precipice which will fall over which
will be extremely harmful may be
devastating for generations not very far
away a generation of our grandchildren
much worse of course for the poorer
countries but also here
well senator cotton of Arkansas is one
of the many intellectual Giants in that
esteemed legislature legislative body
recently announced that we do have a
great deal to fear from Iran because
they control Tehran I know that's pretty
super but you should add that if you
read The Washington Post this morning
you'll discover that Senator cotton was
a real pedigree even graduated from
Harvard is positioning himself to be the
future foreign policy specialist of the
Republican Party taking the mantle of
McCain and Graham he has other
interesting warnings I don't know how
much he followed his career but when he
was running for Senate in Arkansas he
warned the citizens of Arkansas that the
Mexican drug cartels are linked to Isis
and joined together they are working to
send terrorists across the border into
the United States where they can kill
citizens of of Arkansas and of course
all of this is the fourfold fault of
President Obama was leaving a porous
order and so on if that's true we should
move that clock to two minutes to
midnight via a election in Israel
Netanyahu won a third consecutive term
his fourth overall Haymarket author and
Electronic Intifada co-founder Ali
Abunimah says Netanyahu is good for the
Palestinians why because he's very clear
no Palestinian state no compromise
Haaretz correspondent Amira Hass sees
only cosmetic differences between the
two major Israeli parties and she says
that the now moribund two-state solution
is actually a 10 state solution a bunch
of Bond Tostan she says inside the West
Bank what's your view on what happened
in Israel well what happened is that one
question is how much difference there is
between the camp between the parties and
they're all pretty much on the right
others.the there was a very minor sort
of peace party merits got four seats
barely made past the admissions point
the there is the Arab party which is the
third largest but that's pretty much
excluded from any coalition just on
racist grounds no coalition will accept
the IRA party as a important constituent
but there are some differences one
differences if you read Netanyahu's
appeal to the electorate which carried
him the victory after a rather tepid
polling results it was a combination of
outright racism and extreme fear
mongering
so you've probably read in the papers he
warned the electorate that Arabs Arab
citizens of Israel are being driven to
the polls by leftists with support from
foreign governments all in an effort to
undermine his policy of defending Israel
from you know terrorists so on and so
forth and that combination of
fear-mongering and racism does work it
worked in Israel we're not unfamiliar
with it here and it's a very
it's a very dangerous sign about the
nature of Israeli society which has been
drifting very far to the right and this
is a this is a major nuclear weapon
state it's a violent state that's
carried out lots of aggression it's a
direct violation of international law
and the occupied territories that's
accepted essentially by the entire world
with the exception of Israel in the
United States and it can be an extremely
dangerous
it is already a very dangerous state can
be much more so as to the urban I'm on
Emir Haas conclusions I think they're
slightly I don't think they're analyzing
the situation quite accurately the
there's it's widely argued not just by
then across the board by you know
Israeli analysts Palestinians others
that there are two options either a
two-state settlement in accord with the
overwhelming international consensus
which includes essentially everyone
outside the United States and Israel
that's one possibility and the other
possibility is supposed to be what's
called a one-state solution Israel takes
over the whole of former Palestine
Jordan to the sea and then there will be
what in Israel is called a demographic
problem to many Arabs in a Jewish state
that pretty soon in fact maybe a
majority from the Palestinian
Palestinians who and Palestinian
supporters like the one use you
mentioned who regard this positively say
well then it will be possible to carry
out an a apartheid struggle a civil
rights struggle to call for the rights
of Palestinians within this one state
the problem with that analysis is that
these are not the two options the two
options are quite different
one up the second option one state is
not an option there is no possibility
reasonable
ability that Israel will take over the
whole territory and face this
demographic problem they don't want it
the second option alternative to two
states is something quite different it
is what is exactly happening before our
eyes there are policies being
implemented daily right before our eyes
we can see them we can see where they're
directed they've been in motion for
almost half a century and their purpose
is clear what they're doing the policies
tako first of all they Israel is taking
over as taken over what it calls
Jerusalem that's an area about five
times the size of historic Jerusalem
that includes substantial areas of the
West Bank
many former our villages were supposed
to be an internationalized territory
Israel's taking it over in all the
parties except for the very far out ones
are saying yes this is an indivisible
permanent capital of Israel that's one
thing then if you look at the
development programs which are pretty
systematic very obvious the one of them
developed is developing a corridor
extending east of Jerusalem to include a
large town mollado Miam was built mostly
during the Clinton years its purpose is
to subdivide the West Bank to part
virtually partition it the borders of
Malo domain reach virtually to Jericho
which will be left in Palestinian hands
that's right at the border so in the
core extending to the east
pretty much bisecting the West Bank if
you look at the map there are other
corridors to the north including other
new Israeli towns REO through mem they
break up the region further in addition
Israel is taking over its committed to
taking over everything that's within the
so-called separation wall it's an
annexation wall declared illegal by the
World Court by
international opinion but the US
continues to support the policies the
matter
that's a large part of the arable land
that excludes the Palestinians from
their farms orchards and so on
furthermore Israel is systematically
taking over the Jordan Valley that's
roughly a third of the West Bank much of
its arable land Palestinians are being
steadily expelled by one or another
pretext sometimes simply thrown out the
Jewish settlements are being established
that wells are sunk and so on
the traditional method for a hundred
years now of ultimately incorporating
some region inside Israel well you look
at that pattern and you can see what's
happening the the Israel is carrying out
a perfectly reason Dan telogen program
intended to integrate into Israel
everything that might be of any value in
the West Bank but to exclude the
Palestinian population the areas that
Israel's taking over don't have many
Palestinians and those were there being
largely expelled that will leave the
Palestinian population in some kind of
limbo not not within Israel no no
demographic problem no one state
Palestinians lose everything that's the
live alternative there is no serious
alternative that anyone has made any
meaningful case for to think that there
could be one state unfortunately this is
the assumption that's made across the
board but if you think it through you
can see that it's extremely unlikely of
a likely alternative to astute state
settlement is what I just described the
policies that are now being implemented
what could stop them actually one thing
it's in the hands of the United States
as long as the you know the United
States officially
objects to these policies so the
official US policy says it's unhelpful
to peace but the u.s. continues to
support them it's providing the military
economic diplomatic support for them
even the ideological support for them by
the way the issues are framed in the
United States which is quite different
from the rest of the world as long as
the United States continues to support
the policies there is no reason to
expect Israel to withdraw from them
whether it's Netanyahu or Isaac Herzog
or anyone else there are some
differences in the policies the racist
and extremely alarmist rhetoric of
Netanyahu who's not chaired by others so
there's some differences but Amir House
is correct and saying that they're not
fundamental differences in New Mexico
under US law Native American and Spanish
land grant heirs have lost common lands
and acequia water rights have been
separated from the land for commercial
use what hope for the future do you see
from traditional people's continuing to
defend the rights of the Commons and the
shared use of natural resources rather
than exploitation for profit
well again same story it's up to you
these are decisions that the American
population can make in the case of the
United States and of course as we all
know this has been going on for 500
years 400 years ever since the first
English settlers came there's been a
steady attack on the Indian nations
driving them out of their lands
exterminating them expelling them
sending in the reservations that's been
that's American history there are two
fundamental profound crimes in American
history the one is expulsion or
extermination of the indigenous
population the others of course slavery
with its impact still remaining the
United States is as is what's called a
settler colonial society that's an
unusual form of imperialism it's a form
of imperialism in which the imperial
power originally England settles the
country that is being taken over drives
out or exterminates the population
that's a extreme form of imperialism
it's true of the what's called the
Anglosphere of the countries that sort
of extend it out of England through the
United States Canada Australia New
Zealand almost they didn't quite
exterminate the indigenous population
that's an unusual form of imperialism
very for the indigenous people a very
dangerous one and yes they're fighting
back needs support however there's
another point that ought to be made
about preservation of the Commons that's
back to climate change the Commons are
the environment in which we live
if the Commons are privatized if they're
handed over to Exxon Mobil and Chevron
and so on and we're dead for the reasons
that I've just mentioned we're pretty
obvious if the Commons are preserved for
the common good we have a possibility of
surviving if you look around the world
almost everywhere
it's the indigenous populations which
are in the lead in trying to protect the
Commons from destruction by the
industrial capitalist powers primarily
China others so in candidates the first
nations in Australia is the Aboriginal
people in India it's and tribal people
all around the world the countries that
have substantial indigenous majorities
and populations have actually taken
steps
towards trying to preserve the Commons
Bolivia for example which actually has
rights of nature written into its
constitution Ecuador made an interesting
effort to keep some of its oil in the
ground where it ought to be if the rich
countries the European countries would
pay Ecuador a fraction of the profit
that it would have received from us
marketing the fossil fuels the rich
countries refused so now they're doing
also destroying valuable forests it's a
pretty striking fact which ought to
really shame us that it's the indigenous
peoples who have been driven to the
margins of survival who are in the lead
in trying to protect us from the folly
that we are now carrying out which is
very likely to destroy the possibilities
of decent survival that's a the most
crucial aspect of protecting the Commons
the day after the big climate March in
New York and September the very next day
the Rockefeller Brothers fund the
Rockefeller Brothers fund disinvested
from fossil fuels you can't miss the
significance of that given John D
Rockefellers background is this the
start of a major movement in terms of
divestment from fossil fuel corporations
I was important in Oregon recently and
an activist told me this is one of the
hottest issues on campuses at Stanford
to Harvard MIT my on campus it's a hot
issue on campuses and yes it's important
it's in a way symbolic but significant
these are some of the steps that can be
made to impede the race to the precipice
how important it is well like everything
else depends on people like you will you
do something about it
i'ma talk to you about two ships one
fictional and one real the Pequod and
Moby Dick and the Titanic I think it was
Edward Sayid right on this stage who
years ago talked about the monomaniacal
urge of Ahab to destroy Moby Dick no
matter what and to take the crew down
with him it was of no concern to him and
what do you think about that metaphor
that Moby Dick is nature and that a hab
is out there's an out-of-control kind of
capitalism and that when it comes to the
Titanic the reforms that are offered up
by the centers of power are merely
cosmetic they're moving deck chairs on
the Titanic recycle your cardboard
driver Prius and things like that sorry
to Prius drivers
well like any kind of models and
metaphors there's some point but some
differences the crucial we are not being
um you might say that Hitler was an Ahab
let's say he was especially toward the
end of the war he was dedicated to
continuing the war even if caramel was
totally destroyed and it was the fault
of the Germans if they didn't succeed in
winning the war okay that's a have like
in a way but the in our case it's
somewhat different it really is
institutional logic it's not a matter of
individuals those CEOs who voted in the
Davos poll if you ask them personally
maybe they contribute the Sierra Club
then maybe they're in favor of
divestment could be but in their
institutional role as managers of major
corporations they have a duty in fact a
requirement even a legal requirement to
maximize profit and market share and to
ignore what economists call
externalities the impact of a
transaction on others that doesn't enter
into market calculations well in this
case the externality happens to be the
survival of the grandchildren but they
cannot in their institutional role
attend to that problem because their
task is to maximize profit and market
share there's some range of choices of
course and there's some variation among
corporations as to how they operate
but this overwhelming institutional
property happens to be lethal in its
nature it cannot continue if we're going
to serve and survive in the case of
state power it's not dissimilar quite
typically States government's regard
their own populations as a major enemy
the Snowden revelations for example
reveal the extent to which the US
government regards the u.s. population
as an enemy which has to be monitored
and controlled the pretext of defending
terrorism is very weak as you may recall
when the Snowden revelations came out at
first it was claimed by the government
that 50 over 50 terrorist acts had been
prevented by the NSA surveillance under
inquiry they reduced it through maybe a
dozen or so under further inquiry it was
finally reduced to one one case someone
had sent $8,500 to Somalia that was the
net yield of this massive program which
is a program aimed at the population to
ensure their control and obedience and
that's very typical of governments and
understandable the leadership is
committed to power to state power if you
think through the record of nuclear
policy I sampled it if you look in
detail it's much worse but the record is
one of an astonishing record of
disregard for the safety welfare of the
population and steps in order to enhance
state power that's the way powerful
institutions function and these things
have to be to overcome institutional
pathologies is a lot harder than
overcoming an individual pathology in
the case of Ahab you know you can throw
them into the ocean or you submit them
to psychoanalysis or institutionalize
them there are remedies but in the case
of institutional pathology it's far more
serious as for rearranging the deck
chairs on the Titanic
it's
it's not a bad image but but there are
some steps being taken that are not
insignificant the development of the
solar energy for example is proceeding
there are major efforts to try to block
it but it's proceeding unfortunately
this is not the center of where it's
proceeding the major production of solar
panels is in China and this means
sophisticated ones they're at the
cutting edge of advanced technology and
solar panel production should be here
but some steps are being taken there are
some environmental rules but by and
large the primary thrust of policy is in
the wrong direction years ago the
philosopher John Dewey said politics is
the shadow cast on society by big
business how would you evaluate that
shadow today in light of citizens united
and McCutcheon vs. FEC and other Supreme
Court rulings
well Dewey's comment was accurate except
it extends way back back in the 1950s
somebody will remember there was a
Equipe I think maybe it came from
Seawright Mills I don't remember which
said that the United States is a
one-party state of the business party
which has two factions Democrats and
Republicans and that was pretty accurate
at the time but it's less accurate today
the United States is still a one-party
state the business party but there's
really only one faction the Republican
Party has pretty much departed from
being a functioning parliamentary
organization that's not just my judgment
of the
very highly respected conservative
political analyst at Norman Ornstein the
American Enterprise Institute right-wing
think-tank pointed out recently I think
accurately that the Republican Party has
been witty has become what he called a
radical insurgency no longer committed
to parliamentary participation there's a
lot of truth to that we've seen it
pretty dramatically in the last couple
years we're seeing it right now
just take a look at the today's
newspaper the description of the house
budget basically the Ryan budget what is
the Ryan budget through an all kind of
sleight of hand which economist your
smocking about balancing the budget but
what it actually does is undermine
Medicare by moving to privatize it which
means to it's the one part of the health
care system that more or less works
because it's not privatized it's
inefficiencies and costs are due to the
fact that it has to work through the in
highly inefficient bureaucratized
privatized system in the United States
so privatizing moving to privatize
Medicare saying let's undermine the one
system the more or less works cutting
back Medicaid under the guise of
federalism repealing the Affordable Care
Act which sends not a wonderful
legislation but nevertheless an
improvement which will send tens of
millions of people into the uninsured
lists cutting back food stamps and so on
another and enriching the wealthy that's
the one policy of the Republican radical
insurgency do anything he can to enrich
the wealthy and powerful and attack the
general population well you can't win
votes that way so what's happened is
over the last year's the Republican
Party managers
have mobilized sectors of the population
which have always been around but have
never been mobilized into a significant
political force one part is Christian
evangelicals major component of part of
the base of the Republican Party today
you see it in the Iowa primaries coming
up but quite generally another is
nativists people who are afraid that
they are taking our country away from us
which has a basis in fact the white
population is people become a minority
pretty soon and for extreme
ultra-nationalists nativists this is a
crime that cannot be tolerated people
who are sectors of the population who
are so frightened that they have to
carry guns into Starbucks because who
knows who will come after them in fact
there's legislation in Nevada right now
being debated to allow guns to be
brought into daycare centers and maybe
some of these three-year-olds were
trained by Isis Ono's but these are you
know these are not small parts of the
population it's a very strange country
in many ways that's a large part of the
population people can be mobilized on
those issues and not notice that the
policies that their leaders are pursuing
are attacking them and supporting the
super-rich and the corporations
well that's one
that's one of the former two factions
what's the other faction it's not
Democrats its what used to be called
moderate Republicans if you take a look
at the Democratic Party programs there
are a few exceptions like Bernie Sanders
and others but if you take the the core
Democratic Party Democratic Leadership
Council and so on these are the policies
that used to be called moderate
Republicans in fact somebody like
Richard Nixon would be kind of at the
left of American politics today
Eisenhower would be off the spectrum
Eisenhower went so far as to say that
nobody even sane could think of
dismantling New Deal programs mainly the
ones that are being dismantled right now
the current Republican programs are
efforts to dismantle programs that were
initiated under Nixon the drift to the
right during this whole neoliberal
period roughly since Reagan is pretty
extreme actually see it's pretty
strikingly in the public attitudes
towards health towards the health
programs the United us health system is
an international scandal it has about
twice the per capita costs of comparable
countries and relatively poor outcomes
furthermore the US government spends
about as much per capita as comparable
countries but that's a small part of the
health costs because it all has to work
through the privatized health system
which is inefficient your acqua ties and
in the hands of tons of bookkeeping
administration and so on and so forth
and in the hands of institutions we have
no interest in health an insurance
company is not dedicated to health it's
dedicated to making money so not
surprisingly they do things try to make
money
well this if you look back at the
there's an extensive polling record of
public attitudes on health care and for
a long period
since the Second World War there have
been substantive sometimes considerable
majorities a lot of polls depend on
exactly how the question is asked but a
large part of the population and often a
majority has been in favor of national
health care it back to the late 1980s a
majority of the population thought that
there ought to be a constitutional
guarantee for health care national
health care and in fact I think it was
40% of the population thought it already
was in the Constitution
that's the late 80s and take a look
today when Obama presented his
affordable health care program you'll
recall that at the very beginning one of
the part of the program was a public
option allowing people to make the
choice of something like Medicare
national health care at the time almost
two-thirds of the population was in
favor of that but it was dropped without
discussion it never entered the
discussion the United States has a very
unusual maybe unique law which bars the
government from negotiating drug prices
you can negotiate other things but not
drug prices so of course drug prices are
way out of sight much higher than in
comparable countries the population is
overwhelmingly opposed to this there
haven't been many polls but the only
ones I've seen show over 80 percent
opposition there was never even a
attempt to deal with this the power the
pharmaceutical corporations is so
enormous that there wasn't even an
effort to try to introduce it into the
so called Obamacare if you look at the
attitudes towards the so-called
Obamacare they've been pretty negative
most of the population has been opposed
even though for years the population has
been strongly in favor of national
health care and this of course isn't
national health care now some of that
opposition is because it didn't go far
we don't know how much because the
questions aren't asking polls but a lot
of it is the kind of thing you see
reflected in this famous town hall
comment where somebody got up and said
I'm keep your keep your hands off my
Medicare you know that kind of thing
people don't understand that what the
government is doing and what the private
corporations are doing and the effect is
a significant change in expressed
attitudes towards the policies that's a
remarkable triumph of propaganda if you
think about it especially considering
how vital health care is to everyone's
life well those numbers have been at
zero for quite some time and there's a
light up there that says exit but I'm
going to take a moderators privilege and
just go on for a minute or two more if I
may on this that's okay with me well on
this long journey you've been on did you
ever imagine the kind of crowds you
routinely draw or having your books on
display at airports
well actually started giving public
talks on these issues much too late in
the early 1960s early days of the
Vietnam War and started giving talks
about the Vietnam War and as you know it
was talks to three people
somebody's living room or a church with
three or four people or something like
that and it was never and none of us who
were involved ever had it could have
guessed at the time that a couple of
years later there would be a major
anti-war movement but there was and the
same has happened on other issues with
all of the negative things that have
happened over the past years this
neoliberal reaction since lait Carter
primarily the Reagan years there's also
been plenty of progress audiences are
very different than they were in the
past
concerns are different lots of issues
that were fighting issues back in the
60s you could barely discuss them are
now accepted and taken for granted
women's rights gay rights there was no
concern for environmental issues in the
60s now there's substantial concern of
the years there have been amount of
extensive popular activism to try to
terminate the nuclear weapons lunacy the
the general atmosphere of the public has
changed a lot and you know audiences
kind of reflect that well all of this is
positive there's basically two
trajectories there's one trajectory
which one just been describing which is
a constructive positive offers hope
there's another trajectory which I
talked about which is going in the
opposite direction and the question is
which one will prevail but again as I've
said several times and as you all know
without my saying it that's in your hand
you are just in Argentina and met with
some you were just in Argentina and you
met with some activists from the podemos
movement in Spain what were your
impressions well this was an
international conference of activists
and from around the world mostly South
America but some from Spain some from
Greece syriza and others and it reflects
some of the positive developments in the
world
one of the major positive developments
internationally in the past for a long
time long what's he like has been what
has taken place in South America over
the past roughly 15 years South America
for 500 years since the early conquests
had been dominated by foreign powers the
South American countries themselves were
the typical structure was a small
Europeanized mostly white elite
extremely wealthy in a sea of misery and
poverty the elites were oriented towards
the outside they had their second homes
in the Riviera they sent their money to
Zurich you know and so on there was very
little interaction among the South
American countries of the South American
countries were the most religious
students of the neoliberal policies
structural adjustment policies of the
World Bank and the IMF and the Treasury
Department and they were the ones who
suffered most naturally but in the last
10 or 15 years they pulled out of this
for the first time it's a major change
in world affairs South America used to
be regarded here as what was called our
backyard they did whatever we told them
we don't pay any attention to them now
South America is out of control you take
a look at the hemispheric conferences
the United States is isolated in fact
the primary reason why Obama made some
steps towards normalizing relations with
Cuba is that the u.s. was utterly
isolated on that issue in the whole
hemisphere they were trying to get some
kind of arrangements before the summit
of Americas which is coming up soon they
didn't quite make it but that's the goal
this is a huge change and that's why the
conference was in South America but
there were participants from
particularly at podemos and syriza these
are in Greece Europe has been subjected
to a program of a kind of a savage
economic program which is seriously
undermine European democracy it's been
devastating for the weaker the
peripheral countries it's beginning to
dismantle Europe's major per second
world war achievement the Social
Democratic welfare state programs and I
think that's the purpose of the policies
it's economically destructive this is
these are the policies of austerity
under recession even the International
Monetary Fund's is it crazy from an
economic point of view but they are they
make some sense from the point of view
of class war they are enriching the big
banks they're dismantling social
programs and so on well there's a
reaction the reaction was first in
Greece which has suffered most and the
German banks which are basically
responsible for these crises are
reacting in an absolutely savage way to
try to prevent Greece from taking steps
that might extricate itself from the
disaster that's been imposed Greece is
calling for restructuring of its debt
and on delaying debt payments and so on
this is particularly ironic because
Germany in 1953 was permitted by the
European countries
who about to work to cancel its major
debts that's the basis for German
recovery that's why it's the dynamic
center of Europe secondly Germany
practically destroyed Greece during the
Second World War
well put all this together Greece is now
asking for a limited element of what
Germany was granted in 1953 and the
German the powers in Germany the Bank
the Bundesbank are just slightly
refusing in a very savage way now they
may get away with it in Greece because
Greece is a pretty weak country Spain is
going to be harder nut to crack that's a
bigger country a more powerful economy
and in Spain in the last couple of years
two or three years a new political party
developed bananas which by now is
running first in the polls and it is
also a policy of a party dedicated in a
pretty pragmatic sensible way to
reversing the austerity programs
sustaining rebuilding the the the social
economy the so-called welfare state
programs and moving the country towards
and constructive development in Spain as
well the criminals the ones who caused
the crisis with the banks the Spanish
banks and the German banks but they want
the population to pay notice that none
of them believe in capitalism in a
capitalist society say if I lend money
to you and since I know you I know it's
a risky loan and I therefore and I
therefore get a lot of interest and make
a lot of money out of it if at a certain
point you can't pay it's my problem in a
capitalist society but not in the
societies in which we live the problem
is your problem and your neighbors
problem your neighbors didn't take the
deck of the debt that they got to pay
for that's the way our system works
radically antic kappa
was makes sense on class warfare grounds
with no resemblance to markets or
capitalism and that's what's been going
on but there is a struggle against it
and today Maasai worth keeping an eye on
they have sensible programs might win
the next election which is coming up
soon and it's not a it's not going to be
easy for the brussels bureaucrats and
the german banks northern banks to crush
spanish initiatives one last question
you grew up in the 30s at a time when
solidarity meant something there was
mutual support there was an active labor
movement what is it going to take in
2015 to rekindle that spirit of
solidarity well remember what happened
in the 30s the labor movement was in
fact in the forefront
there was cio organizing sit-down
strikes so on
they had a sympathetic administration so
the Roosevelt administration was willing
to accommodate to the some extent to the
pressures developing among the public
labor movement spearheading it which did
lead to the New Deal legislations which
were very beneficial to the population
into the economy but go back to the
1920s the labor movement had been
destroyed there was nothing left
practically nothing left of it one of
the leading labor historians David
Montgomery died recently has a book full
of the house like may fall of the House
of labor and it's about the 1920s there
had been a lively vibrant active pretty
radical American labor movement but it
had been crushed by a brutal attack this
is very much a business run Society and
the business classes are highly class
conscious constantly fighting a class
war have state power supporting them and
they were able to crush and destroy the
labor movement but it revived and it can
revive again and other popular move
gun as well too and there's a basis for
it the basis for it is the quite
positive changes that have taken place
since the 1960s in many ways it's a much
more civilized society than it was at
that time and many issues and I think
that is a basis for recreating the kind
of solidarity mutual aid working
together dedication commitment that is
very necessary today we can't overlook
the fact that we're at a moment of human
history which is entirely unique for the
first time in human history we are at a
position where the decisions that we
will make will determine whether the
species survives I've been true in the
past so we're definitely true now these
are not small questions quite a sobering
note and as we bring this evening to a
close in Hindi there's a word called
Saiva
it means service and I can think of no
one who has performed more save on more
service for humankind than you thank you
very much
[Applause]
he
[Applause]